at this ecumenical service in a church
near Munich two children from a Nigerian
refugee family are being baptized other
refugees staying in the town of puts
balloon have been invited to along with
Elena matzos a German language
instructor who's been working with
refugees for years to Michigan's cut off
fishing for me it's clear that one
refugees flee a crisis region people who
have left everything behind and now have
nothing they're the ones we need to help
first a shared meal after the service
offers a chance for other refugees to
get acquainted spirits are high but not
when it comes to Chancellor Merkel's
sister party the conservative Christian
social Union which governs the state of
Bavaria both Catholics and Protestants
are outraged about the party's general
secretary who's anti-refugee comments
made headlines he said the worst type is
a Senegalese soccer playing altar boy
who's been here more than three years no
one will ever deport someone like that
decades-long ties between the CSU and
the Catholic Church wants our over that
remark the indignation is clear be
exiting Christian it's important that a
christian-based party keep for guiding
principles inside human dignity
solidarity social action and Public
Welfare algum Houston multi-purpose i'm
afraid the CSU won't alienate any voters
because people in bavaria always vote
the same way but it's certainly not
christian values the party represents
puts bloon is one town where the
congregation's are dedicated to
fostering integration as a bulwark
against social exclusion but the CSU
party is widely unchallenged in Bavaria
and that's what troubles refugee aid
workers like Elena mazzio's as if int us
ever platon purple is most think it's
plain old populism the way conservatives
are trying to whip up fears by making
generalizations about refugees that are
completely unfounded no fee Siham on the
also nice person
avena makes regular visits to see the
Nigerian family of this refugee center
she's now become a trusted friend of the
family